hey what is up guys mkbhd here and
welcome to episode number two of youtube
gear so the playlist where we talk about
the gear used to make youtube videos and
this exact piece of gear right here this
particular piece of equipment is i think
one of the most underrated things that i
use i looked it up i bought this in 2013
so i've been using it for like three
years constantly and i don't think i've
ever talked about it on video so this is
a slider as you can probably tell and
it's called the ifootage shark slider s1
and i'll leave a link to this exact one
right below that like button if you want
to check it out there are plenty of
other sliders that you could buy
especially for the price or with other
features but this is the one that i've
been using that i really like now a
slider for those of you less familiar is
something that you can put your camera
on and get the camera moving and moving
on a pretty even smooth track if you
were to move the camera handheld by
yourself it would be a little more
wobbly so this is a way to add motion uh
to make videos a little more interesting
without all that shake you typically
have with handheld stuff so there's a
bunch of different types of sliders you
can get that all have different
advantages and disadvantages different
sets of features this particular kind
has a bunch of neat features that make
it i guess ideal for what i like to do
uh there's you know there's metal
sliders there's sliders that are rolling
on wheels there's sliders that are
motorized this one doesn't have any
motor attached but this was a
belt driven slider so if i unlock the
slider you can see it moves along the
carbon fiber rails pretty smoothly
and comes to a stop without me touching
it so it's inertia driven and then it's
on this belt system which means i can
kind of be like a dj over here and not
even touch or hold the camera
but i can move the slider now another
thing i should mention i don't usually
put the camera directly on the slider i
put a video head on the slider and then
control the camera on the video head so
this is a manfrotto 502
502 502 hd video head and once the
camera is on the video head i can sort
of move the camera around and get
tracking shots and sort of revolve
around it like that that all comes from
just me getting good at using this
slider as a matter of fact i'm gonna cut
together a little montage of a bunch of
clips in the past like two or three
years that have all come from this
slider and you can see how moving the
camera makes for a much more interesting
shot than just a still shot you can
imagine just a still frame of the front
of something versus a little bit of
rotating a little bit of movement a
little bit of action that sort of reveal
stuff can be fun for motion graphics or
just fun for looking cool so this has
all happened
as a result
of this exact slider
get done
so there you have it again even if you
don't get this exact slider if you get
one that's half the cost or double the
cost or whatever it is the idea is that
you're moving the camera on a tripod you
can only do so much with your panning
and your tilting to the point where we
get creative and like move the tripod
around to get moving shots but this type
of equipment this slider is a piece of
youtube gear that can really open up and
take it to the next level and make some
much more interesting stuff now as i've
promised that we will do with every
piece of tech i feature in youtube gear
i will be giving away one of these this
exact shark slider setup
on twitter within the next 24 hours of
when this video was published so feel
free to follow me on twitter if you
haven't already to be able to get in on
that and yeah let me know what other
kinds of gear you want to see featured
on youtube gear episode 1 was a
microphone that i've used episode 2 is a
slider you can tell that there's a lot
of gear going into making videos and
whether or not you get into the gear
that makes it obviously the videos you
make themselves are the most important
part but it helps to have some dope gear
to be able to make that happen so let me
know what you guys want to see thanks
for watching this one and i'll talk to
you guys in the next one
peace